in this video we're going to go over the
hogging face model hub navigation
this is the huggingface.co landing page
to access the model hub click on the
models tab in the upper right corner
you should be facing this web interface
which can be split into several parts
on the left you'll find categories which
you can use to tailor your model search
the first category is the tasks
models on the hub may be used for a wide
variety of tasks
these include natural language
processing tasks such as question
answering or text classification
but it isn't only limited to an lp
other tasks from other fields are also
available such as image classification
for computer vision
or automatic speech recognition for
speech
the second category is the libraries
models on the hub usually share one of
three backbones
pie torch tensorflow or jacks however
other backbones such as rust or onyx
also exist
finally this tab can also be used to
specify from which high-level framework
the models comes
this includes transformers but it isn't
limited to it
the model hobby is used to host a lot of
different frameworks models
and we are actively looking to host
other frameworks models
the third category is the datasets tab
selecting a dataset from this tab means
filtering the models
so that they were trained on that
specific dataset
the fourth category is the languages tab
selecting a language from this tab means
filtering the models so that they handle
the language selected
finally the last category allows to
choose the license with which the model
is shared
on the right you'll find the models
available on the model hub
the models are ordered by downloads by
default
when clicking on a model you should be
facing its model card
the model card contains information
about the model its description
intended use limitations and biases
it can also show code snippets on how to
use the model
as well as any relevant information
training procedure data processing
evaluation results or copyrights
this information is crucial for the
model to be used the better crafted a
model card is
the easier it will be for other users to
leverage your model and their
applications
on the right of the model card is the
inference api
this inference api can be used to play
with the model directly
feel free to modify the text and click
on compute to see how would the model
behave to your inputs
at the top of your screen lies the model
tags
these include the model task as well as
any other tag that is relevant to the
categories we have just seen
the files and versions tab displays the
architecture of the repository of that
model
here we can see all the files that
define this model
you'll see all usual features of a get
repository the branches available
the commit history
as well as the commit diff
three different buttons are available at
the top of the model card
the first one shows how to use the
inference api programmatically
the second one shows how to train this
model in sagemaker
and the last one shows how to load that
model within the appropriate library
for bert this is transformers